the number of rioters arrested and charged
from the January 6th Trump insurrectionist
riots is growing and growing and growing.
And there is a very interesting story well
reported in The New York Times about a guy
named Jackson, Rafet and Jackson.
Rafet knew that his dad, guy Rafet, was in
Washington, DC for the riots.
And two days after the riots on January 6th,
Guy Rafet returned home to the family's house
in Texas and he told his son, I was there.
I was there.
On January six, I stormed the Capitol and
Guy threatened his own son, Jackson, and said,
Jackson Jackson's 18 Jackson.
If you report me to the police, I'm going
to have no choice but to do my duty for this
country and, quote, do what I have to do.
Jackson went to the FBI and Jackson told investigators
that his dad had been there and that he stormed
the Capitol and that he threatened him and
said, if you turn me in, you're a traitor
and traitors get shot.
Incredibly, this was not the first contact
that Jackson had with the FBI about his dad
weeks before the riots.
Jackson went to the FBI and said, my dad keeps
telling me he's going to do something big.
And this is yet another one of those instances
where we find out.
And again, the FBI very busy with reports
all the time.
The FBI's getting reports from all sorts of
different people all the time about different
things.
But this is not a guy who no one thought maybe
had the capacity to do this.
Jackson Rafet had already told law enforcement
that his dad was claiming he was going to
do something.
Big Guy refits wife said to investigators
after the riot.
That guy is a member of the three percenters.
This is a far right militia group.
According to the FBI affidavit, when FBI agents
went to the house, they found an AR 15 rifle
and a pistol.
And the elder Rafet told investigators, I
did bring the pistol with me to Washington,
where he is, as far as we know, not licensed
to have a weapon.
And this is an incredible story because.
No, I mean, this is a story about so many
things.
No.
One, it's yet another one of these stories
of, hey, we told authorities in advance and
they failed to do something.
That is a story that has been told many times.
And we could devote an hour to that on its
own, limited resources, et cetera, et cetera.
This is also an incredible story about a kid
illegally, now an adult, 18, but but someone
who has been observing their father, mostly
as a kid, knowing that their dad was up to
no good.
And because politics tends to run in families,
the kids tend to have the same political belief
as the parents.
The reality that Jackson not only.
Recognize that what his dad was doing was
wrong, actually had the I don't know if I
would call it audacity, but but maybe its
strength, maybe the conviction to say it's
more important that I tell the police what
it is my dad is doing, even though even even
though he's my dad and we don't know whether
the FBI did anything at all about the reports
that came in prior to the January 6th riot.
We know that federal investigators contacted
him during the riots, contacted the sun during
the riots to follow up on the tips from from
weeks earlier and said, we need your help
to prove what we're now trying to investigate.
And it is an unbelievable you know, we I get
calls all the time about my family disagrees
with me and they voted for Trump and I didn't.
And I just want to talk to them and try to
talk sense into them.
This is like another layer altogether.
And I think many of us I mean, listen, I would
like to think that if one of my parents was
involved in something like this, I would go
to the authorities.
Am I sure that I would?
I mean, listen, if it was murder, yeah, I
would.
I don't know what the line is for me.
And so I'm imagining being in Jackson refits
position is just just just incredible.
And now, of course, the elder Rafid is going
to have to face the consequences partially
as a result of the fact that his son did the
right thing.
And think about the bizarre nature of the
times we are living in.
The traditional trope is the parents worry
about what are what's my kid doing on the
Internet?
Is my kid getting radicalized on the Internet?
I don't know.
Started spending a lot of time in their room.
Typically his room, typically men, not women,
spending time in his room on the Internet
and then had all these ideas.
And I don't know what was going on.
This is a reversal.
Kids are having to make the decision to turn
their parents in when their parents have become
radicalized by, you know, Internet news media
messages.
Truly unbelievable times that we live in.
Not an easy position to be in.
And we will ultimately see at the tail end
of this how many of the charges stick and
how many people are actually held accountable
and suffer a consequence for what they did.
A lot of these cases are going to be difficult
to prove in terms of the most serious charges
that could be brought.
We already talked about sedition, sedition
and other charges that require proving intent,
and that's going to be tough.
So Jackson Rafet doing the right thing.
Let's hope it actually leads to charges that
stick because clearly, Guy Rafet, a very,
very dangerous guy.
Let me know your thoughts about this.
And it really is tragic.
I don't see this and say, ha, I see this and
say, wow.
A family member placed in an impossible position
about their parent because of the radicalization
coming as a result of this Trump cult that
has taken place.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman,